il est quelque part derrière ces murs
arrivé hier en milieu d'après-midi
johnattan cavaliers placé face à ses
contradictions
en premier lieu celle qui concerne son
emploi du temps le mari d'alexia est le
seul à l'avoir vu partir faire son
jogging le samedi matin à 9h30
il est celui qui donne l'alerté à 12h30
un créneau horaire aujourd'hui
lourdement remise en cause
et si alexis avait disparu bien avant
que toute la ville ne partent à sa
recherche
technicien de maintenance au sein d'une
entreprise informatique gré l'oise
l'homme disposait d'un véhicule de
société
or un voisin du couple affirment avoir
vu la voiture quitter le domicile et
d'aval vers 1h30 la veille un voyage
nocturne confirmé par le rapport des
experts qui ont décortiqué les mouchards
électroniques
il maintient qu'il a passé la nuit chez
lui
or se pose une véritable difficulté at
il réellement ou pas passer la nuit chez
lui en l'état je suis incapable de vous
affirmer ou de vous confirmer la version
de johnatan des enquêteurs ayant des
éléments sérieux pour bien évidemment
établir le fait que le véhicule
professionnel celui de johnattan à
bouger des empreintes similaire au
moulage effectués sur les pneus de
l'utilitaire aurait été découverte à
proximité du corps de même qu'un drap ou
des fragments de drap un tissu qui
aurait focaliser toute l'attention des
enquêteurs lors des perquisitions menées
hier au domicile des époux d'aval un
élément qui fera peut-être basculé
l'audition du marié blu ray je m'attends
à tout je m'attends l'éventualité qui
est son adn auquel cas ça poserait une
profonde difficulté où vous rendez bien
compte
je m'attends aussi à ce qu'il n'y ait
pas son adn alors est ce que ce sont les
des draps similaires à ceux retrouvés
chez lui je ne sais pas ce qu'on voit
bien évidemment nous
montrez john attah n'est pas soupçonné
par hasard c'est une réalité il ya des
éléments sérieux quand même les
enquêteurs donc je j'analyse les choses
froidement et en l'état je ne suis pas
là pour dire si le latin est coupable ou
innocent johnattan d'aval est il
impliqué d'une façon ou d'une autre dans
le meurtre de son épouse où la jeune
femme at-elle été tuée et quand les
enquêteurs ont jusqu'à 4h30 demain matin
pour faire craquer le seul suspect du
dossier